Right?
Well today is the fourth and final of the contextual lectures introducing 16th
century England.
Um,
we've looked at the social order,
we've looked at households,
institutions,
and relationships in local communities,
and now I want to look at the networks of connection,
the tie,
the whole thing together,
joining up the dots as it were.
So it's a bit of historical geography or if you like it kind of guided tour of
16th century England,
uh,
a bit of historical tourism.
Well,
last time I stressed that local communities had a certain distinctive local
peculiarity or local particularity,
which was partly constructed out of their local customs and institutions,
but it was also something that was influenced by the different ways that they
will link together into the larger world.
The myriad of tiny local communities in this period was on the one hand,
a,
a kind of complex of places which were distinctive entities in their own rights.
But on the other hand,
they were also integral parts socially and politically of larger spaces.
And it's those larger spaces and the ties that bound them together that I'm most
concerned with today.
Okay.
Well amongst the most significant of those larger spaces or what contemporary is
referred to as countries.
Uh,
they use that word not in the modern sense of a territorial state,
but to mean a distinctive area.
Uh,
uh,
landscape,
society,
uh,
in some respects a local culture.
Um,
these countries as they thought of them could be quite localized.
For example,
on the Scottish border TV at Dale or down in Gloucester should avail of Barkley.
These were regarded as distinctive countries or they could use the term more
broadly.
People talked about the north country.
They talked about the west country areas with less distinct boundaries.
When someone said in a letter or in a political speech or whatever that he was
referring to,
the opinion of his country,
he was referring to such a local area.
Touch come trees are usually discussed by historians in terms of contrasting
landscapes,
physical geography,
and to certain extent economic activity.
Um,
if you look at map won the small relief map,
you'll find that agrarian England,
what's customarily divided up into,
um,
on the one hand,
the Highland zone of the north and the West,
you have all the high land represented there.
The highlands zone on the other hand,
the Loland zone of the south and east.
That's one way of perceiving these broad distinctions,
uh,
that were noticed at the time.
And subsequently,
uh,
on the other hand,
people sometimes make distinctions between what they call the field and areas,
areas of practiced,
mixed agriculture,
mostly Loland and various pastoral zones,
practicing mainly,
uh,
animal husbandry.
And there could be a various types,
um,
there where the open hill pastures of the high land,
they were the woodland pastures.
Uh,
much of the west of England was still pretty densely wooded,
some parts of East Anglia as well.
And they practice the distinctive,
uh,
pastoral husbandry focusing on Darien.
Uh,
and then finally there were the pastoral,
uh,
practices of the fen lands,
the areas of eastern England,
which were waterlogged in winter.
Uh,
and where for the most part,
the inhabitance practice,
pastoral husbandry,
it's very distinctive area in this period,
uh,
flooded during the winter.
Um,
the inhabitants regarded as having an extremely distinctive culture of their
own.
In fact to shreds of that continue,
it's often said that,
um,
people from the fence have webbed feet.
Um,
this is,
uh,
this is not true.
I had a roommate from the fence when I was a student and he definitely didn't
have webbed feet.
Um,
though he was a good swimming.
Well,
this kind of distinction in the physical geography,
um,
can,
can be extended to Scotland and Wales,
but there's less variety.
Scotland,
two thirds of Scotland is,
is a Highland,
uh,
only the lowland zone between the fourth and the Clyde is really very good for
agriculture,
uh,
for um,
um,
Arabelle agriculture and areas around the coast.
Wales,
again dominated by the central Cambrian.
Massive,
very difficult in this period to travel north to South in Wales.
And as you go around the coast,
most people,
most of the major routes travel east to west because of the mountains.
So it's as varied.
Okay.
If we turn to another kind of distinctiveness,
um,
there's that associated with the practice of various industrial activities in
the countryside.
That was a matter not so much of the physical geography though that could
influence their location.
Um,
but dependent upon other factors.
We think of this as a preindustrial age.
And yet there were already some areas which were rendered distinctive by,
for example,
the practice of mining and quarrying that clearly dependent upon geographical
factors.
Uh,
you get led being mined in the hills of Darbyshire or in the hills of some
section down here,
um,
iron in the forest of Dean down in Sussex down here.
And Cole was produced especially around the river Tyne in the northeast and in a
scattering of other places across the countryside and in south Wales.
These industries were already established.
And then there was metalworking.
It was a great deal of metal working around the town of Birmingham in the West
Midlands,
which later grew into a great city.
I'm one of England's greatest centers in the industrial revolution for light
engineering.
That was based on its earlier metal working trade.
When Henry the eighth in invaded Scotland in 1523,
he placed bulk orders for arrowheads from the smiths of Birmingham.
They supplied him.
Sheffield was also very well known for its metalworking.
The knives of Sheffield.
We're very famous as indeed to some extent,
they still are.
Um,
most people carried what they'd call the Sheffield wiggle,
wiggle a little knife and you carried around with you to cut your food.
Uh,
and it's from that name of course,
that we get the practice of whittling whittling wood from a Sheffield wiggle.
Okay.
Above all,
there was on a much larger scale,
the manufacture of woolen cloth usually manufactured in the putting out system,
which I described to you.
Raw materials put out by capitalists,
clothiers to workers who spun the wool into yarn,
wove the yarn into cloth in their own cottages,
scattered across the villages around a major urban center and that kind of
organization.
And the putting out system up the cloth industry was very widespread.
Indeed.
Many of the villages of East Anglia.
We're heavily involved.
Parts of Kent,
lots of places in the West country and a number of places scattered across the
north.
We're heavily involved in manufacturing England's most famous product at this
time.
High Quality Woolen cloth.
All right.
All that's fine.
As a brief descriptive typology of different kinds of areas of their
distinctiveness.
Physical geography goes only so far in explaining all this variation.
It's also to do with the not only the physical attributes of the area,
but also invisible factors,
the patterns of connection,
the patterns of interaction,
the flows of goods and people which gave areas distinctive qualities.
Um,
so for example,
to indicate what I'm trying to express here.
Um,
the fact that the coal industry was centered on Tyneside up here in the
northeast of the country.
There's not simply because coal was found there and was found near to the
surface where it could be reached with relatively simple technology.
It was also to do with the fact that it lay very close to the river.
Tyne a major navigable river.
So the cold,
which was bulky and difficult to transport,
could easily be put onto smaller boats called Kiehl's,
brought down the river onto,
loaded onto Kalia ships,
which then transported it,
isn't he?
Down the coast to the cities along the coast and above all to the city of
London.
London could never have grown as it did in this period if it hadn't had a
regular field.
Supplies brought at a reasonable price by coastal routes from the North East.
That's why the northeast became the center of the coal industry.
Whereas other areas which had coal deposits,
we're not yet exploited.
They were too inaccessible.
Well,
that's one example.
One could think of others,
but it's examining flows of that kind.
That's crucial to understanding how particular localities develop their special
qualities and also the way in which they got articulated into larger national
systems.
So do you understand all of that?
One needs to look at these connections and the flows which linked local
societies together into the national whole
one could look,
one can look at those connections in many ways that are the connections which
had to do with the state.
And we look at them next week.
But I look at the attitude of monarchy and the reassertion of royal authority.
There are connections to do with the church and we look at them a lot in dealing
with the reformation.
But today I want to focus principally on connections through markets and through
flows of people.
Demographic flows across the countryside and in particular looking at them
through the pattern of the urban system,
the towns which helped to organize and to some extent channel these flows
well for analytical purposes you can distinguish various levels of connection.
There were local market areas based on a smaller market town linking together
the activities of the villages within particular countries.
Secondly,
there were regional and interregional patterns of trade and finally they were
trading systems of national or even international significance.
And I'll touch on each of them.
In turn,
local market areas were based upon small market towns
within a particular country,
the rural and the urban.
We're not separate spheres.
Um,
it's helpful to think of them as being bound together by connections to a
particular market town.
All towns needed the country's products,
food and raw materials,
the country dependent upon the towns to provide a place to trade.
And also for specialist manufacturers,
specialist's services of various kinds.
So the essential unit to think of is the market town,
its hinterland
and one can distinguish various kinds of market town.
Some of them were really very tiny.
The smallest spawns a,
we're not very impressive as urban entities.
They were just large villages.
Uh,
they've been described as villages with an overlay of urban activities.
market villages.
Uh,
one person rather poetically has described these market towns as being folky and
time.
They just came alive on market day the rest of the time.
They're pretty much just like any other village.
Well,
those are the settlements that provided weekly markets and the range of
specialist services.
Most rural villages would have a Smith the Carpentaria wheel,
right.
But there were other crafts which needed a bigger market.
And so they tended to be located in the market towns.
People like coopers who made barrels or join us who made furniture and so forth.
Uh,
to give you a specific example,
there's an area of the county of Suffolk,
uh,
called Babbo hundred.
There's the name,
that's how it's spelled.
Um,
it's a delightful area of the country.
Recent survey by the Royal Commission on historical monuments found that in that
area,
no less than 24% of the houses date back before 1700.
It's got remarkable level of survival of late medieval and early modern
buildings,
which makes it delightful.
You've probably seen it many times in BBC shows.
Uh,
if you want an ideal English village,
that's the kind of place you'd go to film it.
Well,
Babylock hundred in 15,
22,
there was a survey done of able bodied men,
which led them to listing the inhabitants and that trades and occupations.
There were 32 settlements in the area.
27 of them had only between two and 14 different occupations.
Four of them had between 18 and 27 occupations.
They were the market towns.
And finally there was one place which had as many as 49 occupations.
That was a big market town,
the town of Sudbury,
the name which will be familiar to you know that there are many sub berries in
the United States.
Well all market towns then we're essentially closely connected and part of the
countryside they served,
they gained their living from it,
but they also serve to bind those settlements into what you can think of as a
kind of social area around which people move on a regular basis.
Um,
just to take an example of this,
it was a small village called Kibbe with Harcourt.
It's in,
it's in Leicestershire roundabout there.
Um,
a study of kid with hardcore,
it's been done,
which shows that kid with Harcourt lay,
um,
within a days walk of,
a variety of small market towns.
So here we are in kid with Harcourt,
people who had different things to sell on any given day of the week,
virtually could go out to a market town nearby
and in turn
people were coming in from other villages to those market towns on different
market days.
What you get is the interconnection of the whole area.
Of course,
all the villages from these different communities are gradually intermingling in
the marketplaces of these market towns.
That's how a local society meshed together.
Contemporaries were very aware of this and the cost of the reformation when the
attempt of Protestant ties the country was at its height.
Um,
a good deal of attention was paid,
for example,
to preaching in market towns.
Preachers were appointed to preach in market town.
That was how you reach the people.
That's how you penetrate it an area.
Well,
in addition,
some market towns had a stronger role.
The bigger ones like Sudbury,
which could articulate patterns of interaction over a significantly larger area.
Um,
one historical geographers described these as what he calls cardinal markets,
really important ones.
Um,
linking countries into sub regions.
Very good example is the town of Richmond in North Yorkshire,
which has been,
uh,
quite well studied.
Richmond was placed between the hills of the Yorkshire Dales,
beautiful high country,
sheep country,
um,
wonderful place to go walking or hiking.
Uh,
and the Vale of York,
the Lowland Vale of York.
It channeled the relationship between those two areas,
the sheep and the,
um,
uh,
dairy produce of the details,
including the famous Wensleydale cheese,
um,
which you may have encountered.
It's available in some places in America,
recommended,
um,
big wedge of Wensleydale on top of a slice of Apple Pie,
uh,
eaten together.
This is definitely one of life's more fulfilling experiences.
I do recommend it just sort of,
it's a sort of crumbly white cheese,
tiny,
the best way to Dallas,
still made from sheep's milk originally made by monks from the monasteries in
that region.
Still still produced,
uh,
anyway,
cheese,
sheep wool coming down to Richmond where they meet the grain and cloth and other
products coming up from the,
the Vale of York.
And that's the main center for an exchange in 1536 when the north rose against
the reformation in the rebellion,
known as the pilgrimage of Grace Richmond was one of its major centers.
Uh,
proclamations of the rebellion took place at the market cross in Richmond.
Again,
it makes perfect sense.
This is how you reach people.
Actually speaking of Richmond,
I mean,
you forgive a small sort of divergence.
Um,
uh,
when people visit Britain,
you know,
they're very often,
go to London,
Oxford,
Cambridge,
maybe Canterbury Cathedral,
and then skip up to Edinburgh a or whatever.
Um,
it's well worth taking the time to go to some of the provincial regions where
you can see some lovely places.
Uh,
the north is a very good example in Richmond is a splendid place to visit.
It's,
it's enormous.
Perfect market town.
I've got a 12th century castle perched on a bluff above the river swale,
a delightful streets.
Most of the 17th and 18th century built in sort of yellowish sandstone,
monastery ruins.
It's got everything.
And,
you know,
pick people,
tourists visit places like this.
Very often it's well worth doing.
If you happen to go to Richmond,
I would recommend near the marketplace.
There's an in called the black lion,
which does excellent lunches.
Um,
I mean,
as you'd expect in that part of the country,
the roast lamb is terrific,
but then they have modernized.
They do now have vegetarian options.
Um,
and they have wonderful beer.
The black sheep breweries is a small brewery in that area,
which is very well known.
Um,
and they produce a black sheet bitter.
Uh,
and also,
um,
uh,
most most unusual bottled beer,
which is called rig welter.
Um,
which needs explaining,
uh,
it's a dialect word.
A rig,
welter in the dialect of this particular area of the north of England is a sheep
which has fallen on its back and can't get up again.
You know what I mean?
This,
this happens with sheep.
You know,
they,
they tripped,
they roll on their backs and then they lie,
they're waggling their feet and the shepherd has to come and turn them up again.
Well,
that's in,
in the dialect of the area.
It's a sheep like that.
It's rig welted.
It's a rig,
welter.
And they call this bottle of beer rig welter,
because if you,
if you consume it in unwise quantities,
it has it exactly the same fact.
Um,
I tell you this,
not to encourage you,
but to,
um,
you know,
if you get happen to go to that part of England to warn you against,
the possible consequences.
Okay.
Well to get back to the point.
Um,
so we have significant market towns,
um,
and they connect villages in the localities,
localities into countries,
countries into sub regions.
And that role is revealed in their recorded patterns of population mobility.
As you know,
a village populations,
we're not rooted.
And the mobile people moved about finding work as servants,
marrying,
taking up a tendency of land that was available and so forth.
And to some extent you can trace the distances people moved from their place of
birth in the course of their lives.
Once that has been done of Worcestershire over here on the Welsh border.
And that suggests that people were generally living within 10 miles of the place
they were born.
Yeah.
So it can moving around the country.
And there are other similar studies,
very good one was done of Kent,
of um,
the geography of marriage.
And it found that half of the people in the study married people from their home
parish,
70% married people from under five miles,
84% married people from under 10 miles and 95% married people from under 15
miles from where they were born.
And again,
it gives us a sense of the area in which people were moving around and where
they of course met marriage partners.
Okay.
Well distances like that reflect the area of regular social interaction and
movement shaped by local markets and the towns where they were located,
which created social areas with their own distinctive identities and their own
particular,
um,
orientations.
I've noticed since living in Connecticut that there's an invisible wall across
Connecticut,
which seems to divide red sox fans from Yankees fans,
um,
which presumably has something to do with the kind of orientation of people at
different parts of the state,
you know,
towards New York or towards Boston.
So it's an example of the kind of thing I'm talking about,
the way in which people's connections,
where they go shopping,
where they go for business and so forth,
Orient them in particular directions.
And that's what we created these countries in 16th century England to,
okay,
let's move on.
In addition,
there was some longer distance flows.
Um,
the key commodities that one finds in these inter regional systems of um,
connection and interdependence,
uh,
would have several kinds.
I mean they were food stuffs,
not every area produce enough food to feed its local population.
You tend to get a flow of grain from the south and east towards the north and
west.
A lot of it went up the coast for example,
from east Anglia and in reverse you get flows of animal products from the
pastoral areas of the north down to the south.
Uh,
heading usually towards the cities.
many,
uh,
cattle and sheep were driven in great herds having been assembled,
in the market towns of the north and the West Wales driven down to London in
particular where they'd be fattened up in the villages around London,
but I graziers before being sold to the butchers of the city.
So you get flows of that kind,
you get flows of raw materials.
Um,
the world which was produced in East Anglia,
in Lincolnshire or the North would find its way down to the woolen industry in
the West on the south east.
And one gets other things to the,
um,
uh,
luxury products,
um,
which were traded over long distances.
Things like wine and spices,
find quality fabrics.
They would tend to come into London and one of the major ports like Bristol,
uh,
and then be disseminated across the countryside.
Longer distance flows of foodstuffs,
raw materials,
luxury goods,
and indeed some,
some less significant,
um,
manufactured goods.
The knives of Sheffield,
uh,
were found everywhere in the country.
If you visit London and are standing by the river at low tide,
you might notice people on the mud banks by the side of the river putting mud
into citizen sieving.
It,
um,
they're known as mudlarks there.
Um,
uh,
amateur archeologists,
what they're doing is finding stuff in the mud,
which fell out of people's pockets in London long ago.
Um,
as you probably aware,
um,
uh,
the taxi system of 16th century London was,
well,
little boats on the river waterman road people hit the render that the
Shakespeare in love is a good example of that kind of thing.
If you've seen that movie,
um,
things fell out of people's pockets when they were on the river and they can be
found in the mud anyway.
One of the most common things,
the mud locks find our Sheffield knives.
People carried a knife all the time and they would fall in the river and they
can be found and they end up in museums.
Well,
longer distance flows then any town could have a role in distributing goods over
the longer distance,
but some had a particularly important role and they were of greater than sub
regional significance.
And the greatest of them are sometimes described as being provincial capitals
places,
which in the early 16th century would have a population over five or 6,000,
which seems paltry to modern eyes,
but it was quite significant at the time and which exerted influence over a
whole area of the country.
Um,
to give a good example,
York,
effectively the capital of the north of England.
York was a city of ancient origin and considerable importance.
It was the great ecclesiastical center of the north.
The Archbishop of York was based there in York,
Minster,
Wonderful Cathedral.
Um,
it was a center of royal government for the north,
the king's council of the North sacked at York in the king's manor.
Uh,
and York was also a natural point of exchange for the largest county in the
kingdom.
If you look at your map of towns and counties,
you'll see that Yorkshire here,
by far the biggest county,
well,
York dominated the trading networks of the entire area.
It provided also all kinds of specialists services for the whole of the north of
England.
If your church needed new bells,
York was the only place you would get a bell cast.
If you wanted to buy a clock,
you would probably need to go to York.
Not many clocks were manufactured as very specialist occupation in a tiny number
of the greatest cities.
If you wanted a book,
beautifully bound,
you would go to York.
York had people like bookbinders serving cathedral and so forth.
It's position on the river ooze meant that it was also a town which um,
controlled a major artery of long distance trade.
Um,
the river ooze runs up from the city of Harlan,
the coast up into North Yorkshire and along the river would pass many goods
being landed at Harland coming up into the area or coming down the river and
then being shipped to national and international markets.
Any of the really great cities of the time had that same kind of role.
Norridge was in effect the Capitol of East Anglia and was the second largest
city at the time.
Bristol in effect the capital of the West country.
Um,
Chester very significant also to the north of Wales and controlling trade with
Ireland and so on could go on new castle up in the northeast.
Also very significant,
strategically important close to the Scottish border
just as patterns and population mobility within particular localities indicates
the local social areas within which people moved.
So the patterns of migration to the really great cities tell us about their
regional and inter regional significance.
For Norwich,
for example,
there are surviving lists of apprentices and where they came from,
the young men who came in to learn a trade,
they came from all over East Anglia,
the whole region,
and indeed from further afield,
Norwich was important enough to pull people in from the Midlands.
And the same sort of thing is true of other areas that can be studied.
Uh,
in that way in Bristol,
similar study shows that the apprentices came from all over the West Midlands
and they came from,
uh,
let me just check the figure.
37 different towns and villages of which 25 we're actually located on the river
seven,
which runs up like that.
It's pretty obvious what was going on here.
These places were particularly connected to Bristol was the river trade and
people were coming down river to stop their careers in Bristol as apprentices.
Yeah.
Bristol also do apprentices from Wales and from the southwest of England.
Okay.
Cities such as Bristol or York or Norwich where already places of national
significance.
They focused entire regions and bound them together into the national unit and
they channeled interregional trade.
But the final element of the kind of articulation that I'm talking about,
of course,
is at the ultimate national level and that's provided above or by the Capitol
City London.
Yeah.
As you'll know from your reading,
the English urban system in this period was rather polarized.
There was only one city with more than 15,000 population in the early 16th
century,
and that was London.
Nowhere else could come near rivaling London.
Um,
in the 1520s,
London already had a population of 55,000,
which made it something like four times the size of March.
And it was growing.
Indeed,
it was gross.
It was to grow to a population of something like 200,000.
By the last decades of the 16th century,
London was the biggest marketing center for food and raw materials.
Um,
London supplying London meant,
you know,
farmers all over eastern and southern England was sending their goods towards
the capital city.
There was a lot of road traffic.
Uh,
there was also river traffic down the river Thames,
coastal traffic bringing goods to where there could be landed to supply London.
Yeah.
London was also the biggest supplier of goods that were desired elsewhere in the
kingdom.
It was the biggest center of manufacturing of all kinds of things which would be
sent out to cities and towns elsewhere in the kingdom.
It was the biggest supplier also have all kinds of specialist services which
weren't readily available elsewhere.
London had a lot of lawyers,
for example,
if you wanted legal business done,
London was the place to go.
London was where the Royal Courts,
Matt hearing the most important court cases,
London was the place which had a lot of proper university trained physicians.
If you had medical problems,
it was very rare to find a physician like that,
uh,
out in a small town.
So it was the place to go for all kinds of things.
I mean,
an almost ridiculous example,
if you were,
if you were to break nobleman or a gentleman,
uh,
and you wanted to have a grand renaissance to erected in your parish church in
preparation for your death.
And lots of them did this.
They even wrote the inscriptions themselves while they were still alive,
you know,
saying how wonderful guys they'd be.
And,
uh,
if you wanted something like that and you could afford it,
London was the place that you've got it.
That's where the stone masons work could do something like that.
Uh,
they were manufactured in London to order and then shipped out in pieces to
wherever they were to be erected and then there would be erected by local masons
in a parish church somewhere else in the kingdom.
It's just,
it,
it's true.
But you know,
it's sort of silly example in a way,
but it,
it makes the point
right above all,
London was the great center of International Trade.
The dominance of London was based upon the fact that it was so close to the
crossing across to the Netherlands.
You can have a short voyage across the North Sea to the cities of the
Netherlands and above all the city of Antwerp,
which should be marked on the bottom corner of your Mac,
but seems to have got lost in the xerox machine.
Uh,
in some cases,
London was the major market for English cloth,
which was exported abroad.
And it was the principal place where imports were landed.
In fact,
woolen cloth alone made up two thirds of English exports in the early 16th
century.
Two thirds of India's exports with woolen cloth and at least half of that cloth
went to the continent through London.
It was gathered in London from all over the north and the West of England and
from Wales and export it in fleets of ships organized by a company called the
merchant adventurous.
In return,
all kinds of goods were brought back,
especially from the Netherlands luxury textiles,
fine quality linen silk,
um,
miscellaneous manufacturers which were not made an England pins for example,
they didn't manufacture pins in England.
They came from Holland,
uh,
starch.
They didn't manufacture starch that came from the Netherlands to paper.
There were no paper manufacturers in England.
The book trade based in London of course dependent upon imports of paper from
the Netherlands.
And then there were all sorts of groceries,
olive oil,
fruit spices,
sugar,
wine.
A great deal of this came via the,
the Netherlands is the great trading area of northern Europe with its cities,
notably Antwerp.
And they connected the trade of Scandinavia,
the Baltic and the north to trade down the Atlantic coast and to the
Mediterranean and also the river roots of Europe,
which culminated in the Netherlands,
like the Rhine or brought in goods.
The Netherlands was the center and England was connected to world trade via the
Netherlands.
I keep mentioning Antwerp.
Antwerp was the center of all of this and its importance was very well
recognized.
It was with Antwerp that the English traded bubble,
it's no accident that when Sir Thomas Moore in 15,
17 wrote his book utopia,
he sets it in Antwerp where he presents himself on an,
uh,
an embassy to Antwerp,
which actually took place talking to the sailor Rafael Hitler Day,
who tells him the story of the wonderful land of Utopia,
which is located in his voyages to the west.
Other things came from the Netherlands to ideas.
It was one of the major centers for the smuggling of early Protestant books into
England from the 1520s onwards,
for example.
Okay.
So London's dominant position was reflected in the fact that it had a truly
national migration field.
Study's been done over a thousand new Freeman of the city in 1551 to 1553 young
men completing their apprenticeship and becoming Freeman of the city.
Only a fifth of them had been born in London or the metropolitan area itself.
A quarter of them came from the South East and east Anglia.
A quarter of them came from the Midlands,
a quarter of them came from the north,
and then there were a scattering of others from different parts of the kingdom,
relatively fruit,
few from the southwest.
Probably the importance of Bristol men,
young men from the South West went there rather than to London.
But London's catchment area was truly national.
Okay.
Well this description and analysis of marketing structures and the way they're
articulated perhaps gives a sense of the integrated nature of a system of
exchange already in the early 16th century.
Uh,
and so it was,
it's not difficult to imagine a merchant sitting in his counting house in
Bristol,
perhaps eating some stock fish,
which would have been caught off the coast of north Wales.
It would have been packed into barrels,
which were made with barrel staves,
which probably import it from Ireland by Chester.
It would be salted with salt,
which was produced in the county of Cheshire,
nearby.
I mean,
if he's accompanying it with a little wine,
uh,
that would have come from southwestern France and was probably landed in
Bristol.
If he was drinking that out of a pewter goblet,
the pewter would have been made with led from the Mendip hills and tin from
Cornwall,
probably actually produced by craftsmen working in Bristol itself.
And maybe he's wearing a nice gown to keep the drafts off,
which would be fine quality.
What's did cloth from Norridge and if he's got a fine linen shirt because he's
very well off,
it would be Netherlandish linen.
And that was the best.
The cheap stuff came from England,
from Lincolnshire.
Uh,
and if it starched as color,
the starch would've come from Antwerp probably.
Let's have him cut his fish up.
He uses a Sheffield knife.
Well,
it's easy to imagine that,
you know,
that it,
it,
it mattered that those connections existed and they did exist.
But we also finally just have to appreciate the limits of that kind of
sophisticated commercial interconnection.
Remember what I've said before,
this was still primarily a rural world in which people lived within relatively
contained areas and focused mostly on a little bit of local exchange and
producing their own subsistence.
So most people,
most of the time had only limited connections to these larger flows,
to these larger commercial networks.
The people who were really involved with them were distinctive groups in
society.
Townspeople of course,
especially the inhabitants of the greatest cities,
um,
to a lesser extent.
Also the inhabitants of those areas like the industrial areas,
which we're producing goods for longer distance trade.
Um,
the big commercial farmers who were involved in,
um,
longer distance marketing of grain or cattle and a variety of middlemen who
conducted that trade.
And finally,
uh,
deeply involved in all of this where the social elites,
they were the people who consumed the luxuries.
They were the people who went down to London to attend the royal court from time
to time.
Uh,
they were the people who had truly national social networks
with their equals as members of the elite.
But the point is that the intensity of the integration varied a lot.
It very socially,
it varied geographically.
Some areas were probably pretty densely connected and commercialized.
The southeast in particular,
it has more towns.
It's more heavily populated.
It has a better road system and so forth.
Other areas were less closely interconnected.
Some of the longer connections I've described,
we're flowing across areas where people's lives were in fact much more contained
on a day to day basis when historians try to conceptualize the whole thing,
they have to try to express both the reality of the interconnections and their
importance,
but also their limits.
The continuing importance of localism within your country.
People talk about an elaborate mosaic of interlocking local societies.
Uh,
they talk about what it was still a highly territorialized society,
although a national society also they talk about an AML gam of different local
societies at different stages of development influencing each other.
And yet often a world in which old ways coexisted with the new,
well,
both dimensions of the picture have validity,
commercial relations have a vital place and yet many local societies and
economies,
we're still to a great degree,
autonomous or semi autonomous.
All in all,
it could be described as not yet a fully integrated commercial society,
but a traditional agrarian world with a limited commercial sector
within that commercial sector,
the predominant flows tended to be,
um,
from the north and the West towards the south and the east.
But to imagine it as being simply a dynamic,
advanced southeastern core and a rather backward northern Western periphery,
uh,
doesn't do justice to the more distant provinces.
It's better I think to think in terms of,
um,
certain core activities which are to be found all over the kingdom,
though they tend to be somewhat more concentrated in the south and the east.
But those outposts and those connections really mattered.
They exercise the degree of leverage in local economies,
on local cultures and on local politics.
So we have a set of local societies,
local economies,
even local cultures with important elements of linkage.
It's those links,
those connections that get activated and get elaborated by some of the really
significant developments of this period.
The commercial developments of course,
most obviously perhaps,
but it's also through those same links and connections that people in distant
areas of the kingdom became involved in.
Some of the other major changes of the period,
the so called educational revolution,
the growth of literacy,
religious change,
political change,
what have been talking about really is essentially a framework of communication
which is central to economic life,
to cultural life,
to the political dynamism of the period
and finally the national society as a whole was one which was created not only
by those ties vital as they were,
but also by other forces,
by political forces and by religious forces.
And it's those that I'm going to turn to next week when we come at last to look
at the activities of the early Tudor kings and to what was going on in the
church on the eve of the reformation.
So context done.
Hopefully it will help you to understand the dynamics of change,
which we turn to next.